um yeah that's some real [ __ ] you had uh
so many records that were controversial
did you ever like feel any pressure from
like outside entities when you were
touring because obviously you were you
were kind of like one of the few people
I would say pre you because I kind of
attribute like YouTube to
helping with a lot of people's education
on certain situations because it's free
and it's readily available right and I
feel like when you first kind of uh came
on the scene that wasn't necessarily the
case did you get any blowback from like
the government or did you ever have like
like a Target on your back in terms of
like just some of the things you were
talking about especially to the youth
post 911 you know what I mean I've had
several incidents where police have come
to my house uh Homeland Security
um I didn't become a citizen until I was
17 so they brought an ice officer with
them as if that was supposed to
intimidate me right but an individual
such as myself
is lawyered up the Wazoo yeah
like listen I can't fight the system by
shooting back at them that's what they
want yeah I mean I'm unless I'm I'm
ready to go full Chris Dorner right rest
in peace but if I am sitting there
trying to
get my point across and I don't want to
be censored or I don't want people to
control that aspect of the music then
sure I have to take those precautionary
measures ahead of time of whatever I do
I think being mature enough to look back
as a kid and know hey man these are some
of the mistakes I made these are things
I could have done better they're things
I would have done differently now like
honestly I'm doing it 100 alone now I'm
even more independent than I was before
everything is now Rebel Army records and
just straight Immortal Technique and
then I built a 501c3
um that we modeled after the Black
Panther breakfast party program to be
part and linked to that label it's
called Rebel Army runs and you can find
us it's a charity right yeah 501c3 just
so people don't know yeah it's a charity
um you can find us on the internet at
Rebel Army runs and basically you
remember the projects you were talking
about we've been to just about every
project in Manhattan and now we're
expanding to Brooklyn where we give away
a two-week food pack to the seniors
through that um through their community
centers and through the that nycha
housing programs directly and I just
want to point out to people that didn't
know that in New York City right during
the pandemic they canceled 14 food
programs for people they couldn't afford
to feed those people and we actually
became the functional food program for
the Dyckman houses for the grand houses
which were surfaced this morning by my
team when I wasn't there you can see the
posts right now big shout out to my
brother Thanos and uh the little shorty
little Dominican and shorty Gene that
came and took my place because I do it
myself when I'm not doing a series of
other things wow so it's been a joy to
be able to do that and we've we're proud
to say that um all donations are are now
tax deductible because of our 501c3
status and we've passed the mark where
we fed over 10 000 families and when I
say a two-week food pack I mean we give
them like four to the three four more
cases of um of tuna then we have a two
week oatmeal pack we have canned milk we
have raviolis we give them like tomato
paste we get them pasta and then we like
to have soups in there and then we give
away ensure for the elders and we have
also Pedialyte and Pampers wow and they
have feminine products as well so I
always tell people Revolution isn't sexy
you know what I mean it's not just about
having a beret and running around the
jungle with a gun you got to get your
hands dirty and help people and it's not
always easy you know well I think too
like that's I think that's important to
point out because so many artists that I
grew up listening to around that same
era who I guess will probably perceive
this conscious rappers
and I I don't know if I consider you a
conscious rapper as much as like a
reality art but you know back in that
day there was like the conscious rap
thing and a lot of those guys didn't put
their money where their mouth was I
guess you know what I mean in terms of
like it gets dope to see 20 years later
you're just fighting the good fight man
right fighting to fight for your people
I I can't speak to other people but what
I can say is this I could say that
because my life was personally affected
by these things
um I wanted to contribute back like for
example for the people that don't know
um I went to I got locked up when I was
a kid I spent my 21st birthday being
incarcerated in the hole and when I got
out I thought one of the things that I
could do is teach at a school and what
we did is myself and a young lady named
Carmen Perez
um I met the great Harry Belafonte wow
Harry Belafonte and he said you know you
have such a way with words would you
consider being a teacher in one of these
school programs so Harry Belafonte okay
gave me my first teaching job and I
taught at a school called Horizons so it
was interesting because at the time I
was still kind of touring this album
called the Martyr which did great like
four million downloads everything was
wonderful we turned the world but after
like the tours were over I had the
the really kind of painful but joyful
reality of bringing this right Workshop
which was called confronting trauma
through writing to the kids and the
stories that they wrote were not just
uplifting but they were also
heartbreaking I can imagine sometimes
you feel like you need a shower
afterwards because you realize how much
suffering these kids have been through